But I was with Univac between 61 and 64. That's when I discovered the APL line. Wow. Wow. So you're actually probably one of the very, very earliest users of APL, like literally in the world. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 58, recorded on December 2nd, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we have a special episode with two special guests, father and son, Otto and Eric Niebler.
但我 61 到 64 年间在 Univac 工作。正是在那时我接触到了 APL 语言。哇。哇。所以你实际上可能是 APL 最早、最早的使用者之一，可以说是字面意义上的全球最早之一。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 58 期，录制于 2021 年 12 月 2 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）迎来了一期特别节目，有两位特殊的嘉宾，一对父子，奥托（Otto）和埃里克·涅布勒（Eric Niebler）。
All right, so how should we do this? Before we hop into and we let Eric and Otto introduce themselves, maybe we should tell how do we get to this point? I think at one point, Eric, like so for those that aren't aware and how this would be possible, I'm not sure. I guess maybe this could be the first episode if this episode goes a little bit more viral for whatever viral means for ADSP. I'm a huge array language fan. APL is my favorite language. And most folks are aware of this. And so I think I tweeted something and then Eric, you either retweeted or commented and said, my dad used to code in APL. And then I said, oh, maybe we should have him
好的，那我们该怎么开始呢？在我们切入正题，让埃里克和奥托自我介绍之前，也许我们该讲讲我们是怎么走到这一步的？我想有一次，埃里克，呃，对于那些不知道这怎么可能的人——我不确定，我想如果这期节目在 ADSP 的世界里变得更火一点的话，这也许会成为第一期节目（无论“火”对 ADSP 意味着什么）。我是数组语言的超级粉丝。APL 是我最喜欢的语言。大多数人都知道这一点。所以我想我发了一条推特，然后埃里克，要么你转推了，要么评论说：“我爸爸以前用 APL 写代码。”然后我说：“噢，也许我们应该邀请他”
as a guest on ArrayCast. One thing led to another thing. Bryce got upset that I was trying to recruit people to my other podcast. And then we ended up sitting on me. He's cheating on me with his other co-host. And, and so then we ended up setting up this episode where we have both Eric and Otto. So our first ever, and probably one, maybe one of the only, I'm not sure if there's ever been a father-son combo guest on a tech podcast out there.
作为 ArrayCast 的嘉宾。事情就这样一桩接一桩。布莱斯很不高兴，因为我试图把人拉到我的另一个播客去。最后我们坐在一起……他在背着我和他的另一个联合主持人偷情。所以后来我们安排了这期节目，把埃里克和奥托都请了过来。这是我们有史以来的第一次，可能也是唯一的一次——我不确定科技播客上以前有没有过父子同台作为嘉宾的组合。
I'm like, it's possible it's happened before, but this could be the first time ever. This could be an exclusive. I actually know of another pair, which is Michael Spencer, who works on LLVM and is a C++ committee member, his dad was on the POSIX committee, one of the POSIX committees back when they were part of ISO. And so they actually like they can have conversations about like committee stuff. Have they been on a podcast, though, is the question. No, no, no, not not not yet. We could change that. So, yeah, that's how we got here.
我觉得以前可能发生过，但这次可能是史无前例的。这可能是一个独家爆料。实际上我知道另一对，就是迈克尔·斯宾塞（Michael Spencer），他从事 LLVM 工作，是 C++ 委员会的成员，他的父亲曾是 POSIX 委员会的成员，在他们属于 ISO 的时期加入过其中一个 POSIX 委员会。所以他们实际上可以谈论委员会相关的事情。不过问题是，他们上过播客吗？没有，没有，还没有。我们可以改变这一点。所以，是的，这就是我们来到这里的原因。
And so I'm not sure how we want to go from here. Eric, you want to introduce yourself first and then transition to Otto, or do we do it in chronological order of who entered the tech industry first? What do you think? Let me go first. I'll go first. So, you know, I'm Eric Niebler, currently employed at NVIDIA and working mostly on C++ stuff, of course. And, you know, I have, you know, stood ranges in C++ 20 is a proposal that I brought forward, Currently working on making abstractions for asynchronous programming in C++ suck a little bit less. That seems to be going all right. The sender-receiver
所以我不太确定我们接下来想怎么聊。埃里克，你想先自我介绍一下，然后过渡到奥托，还是我们按谁先进入科技行业的年代顺序来？你觉得呢？我先来吧。我先来。那么，我是埃里克·涅布勒（Eric Niebler），目前就职于英伟达（NVIDIA），当然主要从事 C++ 相关的工作。你知道的，C++20 中的“范围”（ranges）是我提出的提案，目前我正致力于让 C++ 中异步编程的抽象不那么令人头疼。目前看来进展还算顺利。发送者-接收者（sender-receiver）
stuff is going swimmingly. You know, so that's what I'm excited about right now. I've been a member of the C++ Standardization committee for about 20 years. You know, I've been around in the software industry. I've worked at Microsoft and Facebook. I've consulted independently. And, yeah, I mean, I owe an awful lot of it to my dad, who bought an IBM PC in 1986 when they were extremely underpowered and very expensive. And he thought it would be really great for me and my sister.
这块进展非常顺利。这就是我目前兴奋的事情。我担任 C++ 标准化委员会成员大约 20 年了。我在软件行业待过很久。我曾在微软和脸书（Facebook）工作过，也做过独立顾问。而且，是的，这一切很大程度上要归功于我父亲，他在 1986 年买了一台 IBM PC，当时这台电脑性能极弱且非常昂贵。他觉得这对我姐姐和我来说会非常棒。
And he was right. Both me and my sister are in the in the software industry. And yeah, I mean, I mean, I hated computers because it's what he wanted me to do. And I and I refused. I refused to learn anything about computers. I remember in high school I wanted to write my my book reports out by hand, you know, because I didn't like using the computer. My dad wanted me to use this typing, this awful, awful typing tutor program to learn how to type faster. And I hated it. And it really wasn't until college when I kind of discovered computer programming on my own. And so, you know, in some sense, you know, I credit my dad. And in another sense, I got involved in computers, you know, in spite of him. I actually feel great.
他没猜错。我和我姐姐都进入了软件行业。而且，一开始我很讨厌计算机，因为那是他希望我做的事，而我拒绝了。我拒绝学习任何关于计算机的知识。我记得在高中时，我想手写我的读书报告，因为我不喜欢用电脑。我父亲想让我用那种打字练习软件——那种糟糕透顶的打字练习软件来学习如何打字更快，但我恨透了它。直到上大学时，我才算是在某种程度上自己发现了计算机编程。所以，从某种意义上说，我得感谢我父亲；但从另一个意义上说，我接触计算机，其实是为了跟他对着干。其实我现在感觉很好。
But, you know, it was it was there and it was like part of the the water that I was swimming in as a kid. You know, and I I do remember playing text based adventure games on my dad's IBM PC in the 80s. And I and I do remember thinking like, wow, this would be cool. And I remember trying to write one myself in basic when I was very young. So like, you know, the seeds were planted from way, way back. So when I got exposed again to programming in college, I think, you know, I took to it like a fish in water. So what about you, Otto? So were you a programmer, I assume? I was an assortment of things. Right now, I'm currently employed by retirement. I've been retired since 2001. I started out actually, it was the late 1950s. I was working on, quote,
不过，它就在那里，就像我小时候周围空气中的水分子一样自然。我确实记得在 80 年代我爸爸的 IBM PC 上玩过基于文本的冒险游戏。我记得当时想：“哇，这太酷了。”我还记得我很小的时候尝试用 BASIC 语言自己写一个。所以，种子在很早很所以，当我上大学再次接触到编程时，我想我如鱼得水。那么你呢，奥托？所以我猜你以前是个程序员？我做过各种各样的事情。现在，我是一名退休人员。我从 2001 年就开始退休了。我最初入行其实是在 20 世纪 50 年代末。当时我从事的是——所谓的——
computers at that time, which were no less than punch card equipment. I started really when I was in my second year of Fordham at university. I was looking for a part-time job, and one of my classmates was working in the Wall Street area. He said, come on now. I'll show you what a computer looks like. Well, the computer was a Univac Solid State 80, I think it was. It was a punch card equipment. He was doing stock record, which was a basic brokerage back office account.
那时的计算机，其实就是打孔卡设备。我真正开始的时候是在福特大学读大二。我在找兼职工作，我的一位同学在华尔街地区工作。他说：“来吧，我带你看看计算机长什么样。”嗯，那台计算机是 Univac Solid State 80，我想是的。那是一台打孔卡设备。他在做股票记录，也就是基本的经纪业务后台账户。
I was training to be a dentist at the time at Fordham. I saw the computer and I think it was love at first sight. I went home and I said, what do you want to do for the rest of your life?
当时我在福特大学读牙医专业。我看到了那台计算机，我想那是“一见钟情”。我回家后问自己：“你这辈子到底想干什么？”
Walk down the throats of people or you want to do some programming? And I said, I think programming would be my life. So at the time I was living at home with my parents and I said to my father, I'm going to quit Fordham. I want to go into this field called computers. This is 1956 now. My father is old school. And he says, computers, he says, they're toys.
是去掏别人的嗓子眼，还是做点编程？我说：“我想编程会成为我的一生。”当时我和父母住在一起，我对父亲说：“我要从福特大学退学，我想进入计算机这个领域。”那是 1956 年。我父亲是个老派的人。他说：“计算机？那只是玩具。”
He says, they're not going to last very long. Get a real job. Become a dentist, you know. I says, no, Dad. I think there's a future there somewhere for me, you know. So I quit Fordham, and I got myself a job at a Revital Rand service bureau. And basically, it lasted for about, oh, three years, I think. Then I realized I have to get a college education.
他说：“它们不会维持多久的。去找份正经工作，去当个牙医吧。”我说：“不，爸爸。我觉得那里有属于我的未来。”所以我从福特大学退学了，在雷明顿兰德（Remington Rand）服务局找了一份工作。基本上，那份工作持续了大约三年吧。然后我意识到我必须取得大学学历。
So I went back to my family. I said, I think I want to go back to school my father says this time it's your nickel you're going to pay for it I paid for the first half, you pay for the second half so I went back to Columbia as a math major because they didn't have computer science in those late 50s
于是我回到家里，对父母说：“我想回学校读书。”我父亲说：“这次得靠你自己的钱，你自己付学费。我付前半部分，你付后半部分。”所以我回到了哥伦比亚大学主修数学，因为在 50 年代末还没有计算机科学专业。
and it was there I read up on ken iverson and uh the notation that he had and i really liked his work uh so when i graduated i was hired by univac and all of a sudden i found this language called apl and it was Ken Iverson all over again. So I fell in love with the language. It was an amazing language, as you probably can tell, talk about a lot better than I can. But that's what got me really started into computers, too. From there, I had an assortment job.
正是在那里，我阅读了肯·艾森（Ken Iverson）的相关资料，以及他所发明的记法，我真的很喜欢他的工作。因此，当我毕业时，我被 Univac 雇用了，突然之间我发现了 APL 这种语言，它简直就是肯·艾森工作的重现。所以我爱上了这门语言。这是一门惊艳的语言，正如你可能看出来的，你可以比我更好地谈论它。但这就是真正让我开始接触计算机的原因。从那以后，我做过各种各样的工作。
I started out as a programmer, supporting a marketing team. I was in Manhattanortment job. I started out as a programmer supporting a marketing team. I was in Manhattan at the time. So we marketed mostly lower Manhattan applications. And that's what Univac. And then I left Univac, went to GE. GE was just starting up their computer line. And I programmed the, let's see, it was the 200, the GE 200, I believe it was. I was at GE for about three years.
我最初是一名程序员，支持营销团队。我当时在曼哈顿。我们主要营销曼哈顿下城的应用程序，那是 Univac 的业务。后来我离开 Univac 去了 GE（通用电气）。GE 当时刚刚启动他们的计算机产品线。我编写过……让我想想，是 200 机的程序，GE 200，我记得是这个。我在 GE 大约待了三年。
And then I went on to New York Stock Exchange and helped automate their ticker. This is back in the late 60s. The late 60s in Wall Street was a very traumatic period of time where Wall Street finally got the word about computers and started becoming a little more efficient. And they converted most of their operation to technology. And I was there for about three years. We automated the tickericker among other projects. The project I was working on, the Ticker renovation,
然后我去了纽约证券交易所，协助将他们的自动报价机（ticker）实现自动化。那是 60 年代末。60 年代末的华尔街是一个非常动荡的时期，华尔街终于意识到了计算机的作用，并开始提高效率。他们把大部分业务都转化为了技术驱动。我在那里待了大约三年。我们实现了报价机等项目的自动化。我当时正从事的项目，即报价机更新改造，
we teamed up with IBM. IBM did the control program and developed a totally fault-tolerant computer. It was a three 360 50s lashed together and they shared a mass storage device. It was a ferrite core mass storage, but it was a totally full tolerance system. No time lost, no transactions lost. And it was a classic at the time. It really was.
我们与 IBM 进行了合作。IBM 负责编写控制程序，并开发了一台完全容错的计算机。那是三台 360/50 机器连在一起，它们共享一个大容量存储设备。那是一个磁心大容量存储器，但它是一个完全容错的系统。没有时间损失，没有交易损失。在当时这堪称经典，真的是这样。
And then from there. What was that written in? The software part? The the I believe it was written in assembly language. IBM did the programming on it, the control program programming on it. I wrote it was COBOL, mostly COBOL. We had a little bit of Fortran, something called Algol at that time. And that's a variety of languages that we used.
从那之后……那是用什么语言编写的？软件部分？我——我相信是用汇编语言编写的。IBM 负责这部分的编程，即控制程序的编程。我写的是 COBOL，主要是 COBOL。我们还有一点 Fortran，当时还有一种叫做 Algol 的语言，我们用过各种各样的语言。
And mostly a sublingual language. That's where most of the tricky programming was done. Yeah, working with the New York Stock Exchange, I left the exchange and I didn't since that was the primary interface with the New York Stock Exchange to the IBM. They gave me a job. They said, hey, we want you to work on brokerage for Wall Street applications. So we developed applications for about a year or two.
主要是子语言（sublingual language）。大部分棘手的编程都是在那里完成的。是的，在与纽约证券交易所合作之后，我离开了交易所，既然那是纽约证券交易所与 IBM 的主要接口，他们就给了我一份工作。他们说：“嘿，我们想让你从事华尔街经纪业务的应用开发。”所以我们开发了一两年的应用程序。
And then I went on to becoming a manager a while. And then I was into consulting for a while. We did disaster recovery planning for a lot of the major firms in Manhattan, which was probably the most interesting job I had with IBM. But I look back on my record, and the term Rolling Stone comes to mind. I didn't last any longer than three years on any job I worked on, including when I was with IBM. Every three years, I changed jobs. And luckily, IBM had a variety of jobs that kept my interest going. So now I retired. So that's my career in 25 words at once. You told me a great story about the work on automating the ticker.
后来我做了一段时间经理。然后又做了一段时间咨询。我们为曼哈顿的许多大公司做灾难恢复规划，这可能是我在 IBM 做过的最有趣的工作。但回顾我的履历，“滚石”这个词浮现在我的脑海里。我在任何一份工作上待的时间都没有超过三年，包括在 IBM 的时候。每隔三年我就换一次工作。幸运的是，IBM 有各种各样的岗位，让我能保持兴趣。所以现在我退休了。这就是我用 25 个词概括的职业生涯。你跟我讲过一个关于自动化报价机工作的精彩故事。
That work didn't go flawlessly, though, did it? Not really. I think it also illustrates the mentality of Wall Street investors. We took a ticker system that was based on pneumatic tubes. Reporters on the floor of the exchange would report trades on pieces of paper that they'd stick in the amount of tubes, pump it up to the third floor of 11 Wall, which is where the exchange was. And young ladies would take the slips out, get onto a teletype machine, actually a punch paper tape machine, punch it out to Reuters and Reuters would blast it across the world. That's basically the system we had to replace. We replaced it with a Marksense reader on the floor, and the reporter, instead of using pieces of paper,
不过那项工作并没有进展得天衣无缝，对吧？确实没有。我觉得这也说明了华尔街投资者的心态。我们采用了一个基于气动管道的报价机系统。交易大厅里的记者会将交易记录在纸条上，塞进气动管道里，把纸条打压送到华尔街 11 号（交易所所在地）的三楼。年轻的女员工们把纸条抽出来，输入到电传打字机里，实际上是一台穿孔纸带机，把它发给路透社，然后路透社将其广播到全世界。这基本上就是我们必须取代的系统。我们用大厅里的光电马克阅读器（Marksense reader）取代了它。记者不再使用纸条，
he would use a Marksense card. They're using a pencil and a card, and a card in the shape of a punch card, actually. Read it into the reader, and the reader would basically feed it into the 360 configuration that we had. You would format a ticker message and put it out on ticker and send it out. In order to train the reporters on how to use the Marksense reader, we had a training system on the third floor which consisted of a Marksense reader. And instead of the tape that we sent out, it would come out on a Teletype machine, which is about
而是使用光电马克卡（Marksense card）。他们用铅笔和卡片，卡片的形状实际上和打孔卡一样。将其读入阅读器，阅读器基本上会把它输入到我们配置的 360 系统中。然后你就可以格式化一个报价机消息，并将其输出到报价机上发送出去。为了培训记者如何使用光电马克阅读器，我们在三楼设立了一个培训系统，其中包含一台光电马克阅读器。它输出的内容不是我们发出去的纸带，而是通过一台电传打字机打印出来，大约是
the Marksense reader. But there was a slight glitch in the program, my program actually, where instead of going out to the teletype printer, it went out over the ticker itself. And we had a fictitious trade of 1 million shares of XYZ. And XYZ does not exist on the floor of the exchange. And all of a sudden, there was a panic on the floor of people wanting to buy X, Y, Z, but they couldn't find the damn post for Australian, you know? So it hit the papers the next day and it was a chuckle,
光电马克阅读器。但在程序中有一个小故障，实际上是我编写的程序，它没有输出到电传打字机打印机上，而是直接通过报价机本身发送出去了。我们虚构了一笔 100 万股 XYZ 公司的交易。而 XYZ 公司在交易所大厅里根本不存在。突然之间，大厅里陷入了一片恐慌，人们想要买入 XYZ，但他们根本找不到该死的澳大利亚交易桩（post），你知道的？所以这事第二天上了报纸，成了一个笑谈，
but most people had, but my manager was not very happy with that. Credibility was a big, big, an important feature of the new york stock exchange so anyway that's that's the story and it was it was probably pretty hard to get the you know the wall street uh industry to um to believe in and have confidence in this new you know that was the big concern that was the big concern by the New York Stock Exchange. They pride themselves in being the blue chip exchange of New York, the world actually. And credibility is very, very important.
大多数人都……但我的经理对此很不高兴。信誉是纽约证券交易所一项非常、非常重要的特质。不管怎样，这就是故事。让华尔街……这个行业去相信并对这种新事物建立信心，可能相当困难吧？那是最大的担忧，那是纽约证券交易所最大的担忧。他们以为自己是纽约——实际上是全世界——的蓝筹交易所而自豪。而信誉是非常非常重要的。
That mistrade is very, very important. The way they recovered from that was a message on the ticket following that ticker, the following day, which we did it during trading hours. We put a correction message out of the ticket saying, disregard this message of XYZ. But it was too late. The horses were out of the barn at that point. They were running like hell.
那次错误交易非常、非常严重。他们恢复信誉的方式是在第二天交易时间内，在报价机上紧接着上一条报价发布一条消息。我们发出了一条修正消息，说：“请忽略关于 XYZ 的这条消息。”但为时已晚。那时马已经跑出马厩了，它们正拼命狂奔呢。
And so it gives you an idea of the mentality of how much an investigation goes on in investing on a hot stock, which they thought it was a hot stock. A company that didn't even exist. Yeah. So to rewind to the back because i'm super curious so you said that you basically set eyes on a computer for the first time in 56 um it was a punch card it was the solid state i think the univac solid state 80 yeah so that was 56 then you went uh and worked
这让你对炒作某只他们以为是热门股票的炒股心态有了一个概念——哪怕那只股票根本不存在。是的。所以我们倒回前面聊聊，因为我超级好奇。你说你基本上是在 56 年第一次亲眼见到计算机，嗯，那是一台打孔卡，那是 Univac Solid State 80，对吧？所以那是 56 年，然后你去了……
for three years then went back to school and it sounds like you actually ran into Iverson Notation first. And that's what you mentioned by Ken Iverson's work. And then later on. I was in Columbia, yeah. Yeah, so that was at Columbia. Yeah. And then later on, you ran into APL. So for folks that don't know the timeline, if that's the that's the late fifties or 1960 at that time, when you're at Columbia,
工作了三年，然后又回学校上学，听起来你实际上是先遇到了艾森记法（Iverson Notation）。这就是你提到的肯·艾森的工作。然后后来……我在哥伦比亚大学，是的。是的，那是在哥伦比亚大学。是的。然后后来，你遇到了 APL。所以对于那些不了解时间线的人来说，如果是 50 年代末或 1960 年代，当你还在哥伦比亚大学时，
APL doesn't exist at that point in time. It's not until 1962 that Ken Iverson actually publishes his book and they don't actually have an APL implemented that you can code it until I think it's 66 or 67. So that's super, super easy. I was working for a Univac 61 through 64. It was in Univac. I saw, I used the APL line. Oh, really? So that must, that must've been in its first, you know, in its early development stages. It was, it was a relatively new language as I recall. It was myself and this other guy that was very interested in it as well.
APL 在那个时间点并不存在。直到 1962 年肯·艾森才出版了他的书，而且直到 66 或 67 年左右，他们才真正实现了一个可以编写代码的 APL。所以这超级、超级……我是在 61 到 64 年间为 Univac 工作的。正是在 Univac，我看到了、使用了 APL 语言。哦，真的吗？所以那一定是在它的早期，你知道的，在其早期开发阶段。如我所记，那是一门相对较新的语言。当时是我和另外一个人，他也对它非常感兴趣。
He introduced me to the Iverson notation, and I got hooked into it. And together, we were just screwing around with it to see what we could do with it. But I know that I was able to do a hell of a lot more with that language than I can with BASIC, which is what I was used to writing or an assembly language. But I was with UNIVAC between 61 and 64. That's when I discovered the APL language. Wow. That's even, I think, that must have been like an implementation by UNIVAC or something.
他向我介绍了艾森记法，我深深地迷上了它。我们俩就在那儿瞎琢磨，看看能用它做些什么。但我知道，与我习惯编写的 BASIC 语言或汇编语言相比，我用那种语言能干成多得多的事情。但我是在 61 到 64 年间在 UNIVAC 工作。正是在那时我发现了 APL 语言。哇。这甚至，我想，那一定是由 UNIVAC 或其他机构实现的版本。
It may have been a beta version that we got our heads on. I got no idea. All I know is I didn't use it during that period of time. Wow. Wow. So you're actually probably one of the very, very earliest users of APL,
那可能是我们搞到手的测试版（beta version）。我不知道。我只知道我当时确实在那段时期使用过它。哇。哇。所以你实际上可能是 APL 最早、最早的使用者之一，
literally in the world. I wouldn't categorize myself as a user. I mean, we, we feel, we fooled around with it, but yeah, I did. We did not do any kind of productive work with it. I don't think I did any productive work with it either. And so what would you say of the languages that you've sort of programmed with? Cause it sounds uh the three apl or the three 360s that were tied together for that you mentioned a slew of languages fortran cobalt
字面意义上的全球最早之一。我不会把自己归类为什么“使用者”。我的意思是，我们……我们只是瞎胡闹罢了，是的，我确实用过。我们没有用它做过任何有生产力的工作。我想我当时也没用它做过任何有生产力的工作。那么，对于你曾经用之编程的那些语言，你会怎么评价呢？因为听起来，你提到的那三个 APL，或是连在一起的三台 360，你提到了一大堆语言：Fortran、COBOL、
algol um i'm not sure if you mentioned basic in that run and assembly was the main one uh did you spend like most of your career working with any one of those or did you were you basically a polyglot actually i was not the one working. I was a manager at that time. I had a staff of people who were working on it. My particular responsibility for that project was to develop the application side of it and to interface with IBM on a control program.
Algol，我不确定你在那次运行中是否提到了 BASIC，汇编则是主要的语言。你职业生涯的大部分时间都在使用其中某一种语言，还是说你基本上是个多语言者？实际上，我不是那个具体写代码的人。我当时是一名经理。我手下有一群人在做这个。我负责那个项目的特定职责是开发应用程序端，并与 IBM 接口对接控制程序。
We laid down specs for the control program on what IBM was to do. But the team I had, we were basically application programs. And so how did the team or the folks that were working for you, did they, I guess at that time, like these days, a lot of times when you're building something, you have a team of engineers, not that there's a vote or something, but everyone has their, oh, I want to code this in C++ or Rust. It was not up to them. It was divided up by the function that they were addressing with the software go with the macro languages like Cobalt and, I'm sorry,
我们为 IBM 应该做什么样的控制程序制定了规范。但我手下的团队基本上是应用程序员。那么你的团队或者为你工作的人，他们是如何……我猜在那个时代，就像现在很多时候你构建某些东西时，你有一支工程师团队，倒不是说要进行什么投票，但每个人都有自己的想法：“噢，我想用 C++ 或 Rust 编写代码。”这不是他们能决定的。任务是根据软件所解决的功能来划分的，宏语言比如 COBOL 和，对不起，
Fortran and Album. The more stringent type of, the more complicated type of programming, we usually wound up doing it in assembly language because we had the most control at that time. And when, so Eric, when did you enter this? So I assume, you know, back in 56, you clearly weren't alive yet. So at what point, at what point did you enter? Yeah. I don't know how old you are, but I'm guessing it was, you're not that old. No, no. I came into the picture in 1973. Yeah. That's when I was born.
Fortran 和 Algol。那种更严格的、更复杂的编程，我们通常最终会用汇编语言来做，因为当时我们拥有最大的控制权。那么，埃里克，你是什么时候加入进来的？所以我想，早在 56 年的时候，你显然还没出生呢。那么你在什么时候、在哪个时间点加入的？是的。我不知道你多大了，但我猜……你没那么老吧。不，不。我是 1973 年出生的。是的。那是我出生的时候。
And you said you got that first IBM PC in 86? I think so. Yeah. Because, you know, I know that there was a computer that was bought in 86. I don't know if it was the first IBM PC that my dad bought. It was. Okay. Okay. Okay. Because I know this because several years, maybe 10, 15 years ago,
你刚才说你在 86 年买的那台第一台 IBM PC？我想是的。因为，你知道的，我知道确实在 86 年买过一台电脑。我不知道那是不是我爸爸买的第一台 IBM PC。是的。好吧。好吧。好吧。因为我知道这一点，是因为几年后——也许是 10 年、15 年前——
I went down to my parents' basement and the machine was still there, actually, in the basement. And I was very excited because the keyboards that came with those PCs are legendary. The IBM model M keyboard. And, and so I, I, I took it. I mean, it was, it was filthy. It was like completely encrusted over. So I like meticulously took it apart and cleaned every piece of it and reassembled it and brought it back to Seattle with me, which is where I live. And, and I know,
我去了我父母的地下室，那台机器实际上还在地下室里。我当时非常兴奋，因为那些 PC 附带的键盘是传奇级别的。IBM Model M 键盘。所以，我把它拿走了。我的意思是，它当时……太脏了。完全结了一层厚厚的东西。所以我像强迫症一样把它拆开，清洗了每一个部件，重新组装好，然后把它带回了我居住的西雅图。而且我知道，
I know it's from 1986 cause cause all IBM model M keyboards have, have their birth date on, on the back of them. And that keyboard was made in October, 1986. And do you still have it? so this is a really sad story oh no um yeah this is a sad story and i can tell you haven't seen my cpp con talk yet because i talk about it there so shame on you from this uh 2021 right yes okay i haven't seen it yet i haven't seen any of the cpp con talks because they're not they're like hidden on YouTube still, I think. No, no, this one is actually public on YouTube. You can find it now.
我知道它是 1986 年产的，因为所有的 IBM Model M 键盘背面都有它们的出生日期。那个键盘是 1986 年 10 月制造的。你现在还留着它吗？所以这是一个非常悲伤的故事。噢，不……是的，这是一个悲伤的故事，我敢说你还没看过我的 CppCon 演讲，因为我在那里谈过这件事。所以你真该感到羞愧，从这个……2021 年的对吧？是的。好吧，我还没看过。我还没看过任何 CppCon 的演讲，因为它们好像还在 YouTube 上被隐藏着，我想。不，不，这个实际上在 YouTube 上是公开的。你现在就能找到它。
The keyboard traveled with me wherever I went and I loved it. And this is the keyboard that I use day to day. And I started working at Facebook and of course I brought it to work with me and it was there on my desk at Facebook when lockdown happened due to the pandemic. And I, you know, like the rest of the world, didn't really appreciate at the time exactly how long lockdown would happen. It would be so. So I left a lot of stuff at my desk i'm like i'm gonna come back to this in a few weeks it'll be fine um but um but then uh then you know like we were still off uh you know in lockdown and then like office moves happened and then uh i i changed jobs to NVIDIA. And like, I never got back to the office to reclaim my stuff. And nobody knows what happened to that keyboard. It has just vanished into thin air.
那个键盘无论我走到哪里都跟着我，我非常喜欢它。这就是我日常使用的键盘。后来我开始在 Facebook 工作，理所当然地我把它带到了公司。当大流行导致封城时，它就安放在我在 Facebook 的办公桌上。而我和其他人一样，当时并没有真正意识到封城会持续多久。所以我把很多东西留在了办公桌上，心想：“我几周后就会回来，没事的。”但是……但后来，你知道的，我们仍然处于封城状态，接着发生了办公室搬迁，然后我换工作去了 NVIDIA。结果，我再也没有回到办公室去取回我的东西。没有人知道那个键盘发生了什么。它就这么凭空消失了。
So I am like bereft. I am like heartbroken because this is the keyboard that I learned to program on in the 80s. It's the keyboard that I played, you know, Decathlon on in 1987. You know, it's the keyboard that I played Zork 1 on, you know, this text-based adventure game. And, you know, I remember sitting next to my, my best friend at the time, and we were, you know, hammering away on that keyboard, playing, playing games, like really awful eighties PC games, really bad games that we absolutely loved. And of course that,
所以我感到被剥夺了一切。我心碎欲绝，因为这是我在 80 年代学习编程的键盘。这是我在 1987 年玩十项全能（Decathlon）的键盘。这是我玩《佐克 1》（Zork 1）——那个基于文本的冒险游戏——的键盘。而且，我还记得坐在我当时最好的朋友旁边，我们在那个键盘上疯狂敲击，玩游戏，玩那些非常糟糕的 80 年代 PC 游戏，那些我们绝对热爱的大烂游戏。当然，
that keyboard, you know, the reason why it's so legendary is because it's like absolutely indestructible. Like that keyboard, you know, the reason why it's so legendary is because it's like absolutely indestructible. Like that keyboard weighed more than like more than my laptop. You could clock someone over the head with it. It would do real damage. It had this big steel plate on the bottom of it, you know, to make it like super like heavy and stable. So it wouldn't bounce around when you were typing on it.
那个键盘之所以如此传奇，是因为它绝对不可摧毁。那个键盘……之所以传奇，是因为它绝对坚不可摧。那个键盘的重量比……比我的笔记本电脑还要重。你可以用它砸别人的脑袋。它真的能造成伤害。它的底部有一块厚重的大钢板，你知道的，为了让它变得超级重、超级稳，这样你在打字时它就不会晃来晃来晃去。
So anyway, like I have no idea what happened to this keyboard. It's out there somewhere. It unfortunately doesn't have my name on it. I should have written my name on it. But if somebody at Facebook hears this and they, you know, they have somehow inherited an IBM Model M keyboard, they don't know where it came from. And if they check the bottom and it says October 1986 on it, please reach out to me. Listeners, this is our mission to you. Help us
所以无论如何，我不知道这个键盘怎么样了。它现在不知流落何方。不幸的是上面没有我的名字。我当初应该把我的名字写在上面的。但如果 Facebook 的某个人听到这话，他们……不知怎么地继承了一个 IBM Model M 键盘，却不知道它从哪来，如果他们检查底部发现上面写着“1986 年 10 月”，请联系我。听众们，这就是给你们的任务。帮我们
locate my lost IBM Model M keyboard. Yeah. This podcast now has two goals. One, to be number one in Slovenia. We love you, Slovenia. And two, to track down this keyboard. I mean, I'm not saying that's why Facebook rebranded to Meta. I've heard lots of reasons, but potentially Zuckerberg is trying to cover up the tracks of this keyboard. It sounds like this keyboard is probably worth quite a bit if you sold it online. I was, I was actually going to ask Otto, do you remember how much that IBM PC would have cost in like when you bought it in 86? I remember. You remember the amount that we paid? I paid for it. I believe it was $2,500. I'm sorry. It was $2,500. Yeah.
找到我丢失的 IBM Model M 键盘。是的。这个播客现在有两个目标。第一，在斯洛文尼亚排名第一。我们爱你，斯洛文尼亚。第二，追踪到这个键盘。我的意思是，我并不是说这就是 Facebook 更名为 Meta 的原因。我听过很多原因，但扎克伯格可能正试图掩盖这个键盘的踪迹。听起来如果你把它在网上卖掉，这个键盘可能相当值钱。我本来想问奥托，你还记得 86 年买那台 IBM PC 的时候大概花了几千块吗？我还记得。你还记得我们付的金额吗？我付的。我相信是 2,500 美元。对不起。是 2,500 美元。是的。
I remember, I remember mom making a stink about it because it was five grand. Five grand. You know, you're probably right. You're probably right. In today's dollars, it's well over $10,000. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, five grand.
我记得，我记得妈妈为此大发雷霆，因为那是五千块。五千块。你知道的，你可能是对的。你可能是对的。换算成今天的美元，绝对远超 10,000 美元。对，对。对，五千块。
And yeah, it was like a toy, right? It was like a pocket calculator. It was almost grounds for divorce divorce too, by the way. Yeah. Well, yeah, it's interesting. The reason I ask is because, you know, it's not something, you know, it was not a small purchase at the time. It was not common for people to have a computer in the house.
是的，就像个玩具对吧？就像个袖珍计算器。顺便说一句，这几乎达到了离婚的边缘。是的。好吧，是的，很有趣。我问这个的原因是，你知道的，那可不是一笔小买卖。当时家里有台电脑可不常见。
That's true. It was. But it was a must for me. It was a must have. You know, computers were very, very novel. I think people who were addicted to it, like I was, had to have it, okay, regardless of how much it cost. Like with an IBM machine and you were working for IBM at the time, did you get some sort of company discount?
确实如此。但对我来说那是必须的。那是必不可少的。你知道的，计算机非常、非常新奇。我觉得那些像我一样对它上瘾的人，无论花多少钱都必须拥有一台，好吧。就像拥有一台 IBM 机器，你当时在 IBM 工作，能享受某种公司折扣吗？
I probably did. And I'm trying to remember how much. It was not a lot. In that respect, IBM was not that generous in terms of company discounts like that. The IBM, that particular model of IBM was hard to come by because they felt customers had to come first before the employees. So we were at the bottom of the food chain on this one. Was that an AT or an XT or what was that? It was an XT. I believe it was an XT. XT, I think, preceded an AT, didn't it? I'm not sure. I think, I don't remember.
我大概是有的。我在努力回想具体是多少。并不多。在这方面，IBM 在这种公司折扣上并不是那么慷慨。那个特定型号的 IBM 机器很难买到，因为他们觉得客户必须排在员工前面。所以在这一点上，我们处于食物链的最底层。那是 AT 还是 XT，或者那是什么？那是 XT。我相信那是 XT。XT，我没记错的话，应该在 AT 之前吧？我不确定。我想，我不记得了。
I'll get it wrong. I thought the AT came first, but I'm not sure. I could be right. It's been over 50 years for me. So one thing I do know is that keyboard, like it has this long, like, telephone cable, this black telephone cable, right? And it's coil, so you could, like, you know, walk around with it, you know. It was portable. Yeah, sure.
我会记错的。我以为 AT 先出来，但我不确定。我可能是对的。对我来说已经过去 50 年了。我确实知道的一件事是，那个键盘，它有一根很长的、像电话线一样的黑色电话线，对吧？它是盘绕的，所以你可以拿着它走来走去。它是便携的。没错，确实。
And the plug, like where you stuck it into the computer, it was this big fat, like nine pin, I think, nine pin thing. And those plugs are called AT plugs. So that's why I think the AT came first because that was probably the first computer that used that plug and so it got called the AT plug.
至于插头，就是你把它插进电脑的地方，是一个又粗又大的、大概九针的东西。那些插头被称为 AT 插头。这就是为什么我认为 AT 先出来，因为那可能是第一台使用这种插头并因此被称为 AT 插头的电脑。
It looks like the AT came second. The AT was 84. The XT was 83. I had the earlier one. Is this just a computer model for those that are out of the loop like me? I think that was an 8088 processor. 8088. You're right.
看起来 AT 是第二个出来的。AT 是 84 年的。XT 是 83 年的。我用的是更早的那款。这只是针对像我这样状况外的听众的电脑型号吗？我想那是 8088 处理器。8088。你说的对。
I think, but this is like the IBM's first home PC. Yeah. Was that the first one, the XT? I believe it was the first one. But the keyboard was not the first one. That came out of its office products division. That was being used by the office products for their devices. So the keyboard preceded that desktop
我想，但这就像是 IBM 的第一台家用 PC。是的。那是第一台吗，XT？我相信那是第一台。但键盘可不是第一款。那是从他们的办公产品部门出来的。办公产品部门一直在将它用于他们的设备。所以键盘的诞生比那个桌面电脑要早得多
long before the desktop was created. I didn't know. So that was like the second chip that Intel made, basically. Oh. Yeah. That's what I learned to program on. Wow. Yeah. I was writing was writing basic for that.
早在桌面电脑被创造出来之前。我不知道。所以那是英特尔制造的第二块芯片，基本上。哦。是的。那就是我学习编程的机器。哇。是的。我当时在那上面写
Really bad text-based adventure games. One event that sort of made me consider Eric for computers, that he wrote a basic program, I think while he was in his early teens. And it was a very simple program, but it tested my hearing. And it discovered that I had a hearing loss in the higher range frequencies, which happens to be true today. But he discovered it when he was, I think, 14 or 15 years old with his basic program. I knew that he was meant for computers, even though he fought it tooth and nail. I knew he was meant to be for computers. It was the simplest program. It was probably like
非常糟糕的基于文本的冒险游戏。有一件事让我开始考虑让埃里克接触计算机，他在十几岁的时候写了一个 BASIC 程序。那是个非常简单的程序，但它测试了我的听力。它发现我在高频范围有听力损失，这在今天是确实存在的。但他发现这一点时，我想他只有 14 或 15 岁，用的就是他的 BASIC 程序。我知道他是为计算机而生的，尽管他对此进行了激烈的反抗。我知道他注定属于计算机。那是最简单的程序。可能就像
10 lines of code. Somehow I learned how to control the speaker and play tones. And it just started real low and went up real high. And it was like, did you hear this? Yes or no. Right. And we were absolutely stunned when when my dad was like, I think there's something wrong with the program. Like it didn't. And we were all dumbfounded because you're like, you didn't hear that. Wow. So at first you at first you thought that the program didn't work uh and that maybe he wasn't uh destined to be computed and then you realize don't wait it does work it's just a couple lines it's my hearing that's uh not working wow that's uh that's pretty amazing um that you were but you were like a little medical
10 行代码。不知怎么的，我学会了如何控制扬声器并播放音调。它从很低的频率开始，一直升高到很高的频率。就像：“你听到这个了吗？是或否。”对。当爸爸说“我觉得这个程序有点问题”时，我们彻底惊呆了。就像它没有……我们都目瞪口呆，因为你当时说：“你没听到那个吗？”哇。所以一开始你以为程序没用，
programmer back then. I guess so. That and the text-based adventure games, the only programs I actually remember. Oh, that and copying programs out of Byte Magazine with my friend, you know, and trying to get those programs to work. But they never did, you know, because, you know, the print in those Byte Magazines was like, OK, I can't tell if this is an O or a zero or, you know, what, you know, the print in those bite magazines was like, okay, I can't tell if this is an O or a zero or, you know, what, what, what, what is this thing anyway? And then, and then you'd make like one typo and the whole program wouldn't work. And then you'd have to go back meticulously and find, you know, it was, it was pain, painful. But I guess that was, that was the fun of programming back then. I don't know. Yeah. Because that used to be how,
觉得他可能不是注定要搞计算机的，然后你意识到，等一下，它确实有用，只是那几行代码测试出我的听力不行了。哇，那真是太神奇了……你当时就像个小小医学程序员。我猜是的。除了那个，就是基于文本的冒险游戏，那是我唯一真正记得的程序。哦，还有和我的朋友一起从《Byte》杂志上抄程序，你知道的，试图让那些程序跑起来。但它们从来没跑通过，你知道的，因为《Byte》杂志上的印刷体实在是……“好吧，我分不清这是字母 O 还是数字零，或者……这到底是个啥东西？”然后呢，只要你有一个拼写错误，整个程序就无法运行。接着你就得一针见血地回去查找错误。太痛苦了。但我想那就是当年编程的乐趣所在吧。不知道。是的，因为对所有年轻听众来说，
for all the young listeners, that used to be how programs would get distributed before you... Yeah, that was open source. ...sent them around on floppy disks. They'd be in some magazine. You'd have to... They'd be in a magazine.
以前程序就是这样分发的，在你……对，那就是开源。……把它们刻在软盘上到处传之前。它们会印在某本杂志里。你必须……它们会印在杂志上。
You had to type it in. Yeah, exactly. That was programming in the early days of my early days, you know, not my dad's era. Oh, my days. The actual testing of a program was a hell of a lot more difficult than it is today. We would get maybe one or two turnarounds a day. And by a turnaround, it's submitting a test to a computer and getting the results back within one day. So the term interactive programming did not exist with us.
你得手动敲进去。是的，绝对的。那是我早年——不是我爸爸那个时代——编程的日子。天哪。实际测试程序比今天要困难得多。我们一天可能只能得到一两次周转（turnaround）。所谓的周转，就是把测试提交给计算机，并在一天之内拿回结果。所以交互式编程这个词对我们来说是不存在的。
It was you had to literally assemble, test and then print out the core dump. And from that, you were able to debug a program. So we were lucky if we got one, if not two turnarounds a day. Yeah, that's that's actually it's very similar to when I worked in supercomputing, high performance computing. If you had an application where you were running it at scale, you know, you were running it on half the supercomputer, the whole supercomputer, and you had some bug at that scale, you know, it would take you 24 hours or 48 hours to submit the job to the system that you know would go and run there and then you'd get your result back and and you wouldn't you wouldn't it wouldn't be interactive at all it would run you know at 3 a.m sometime and you'd have to do your best to debug based on what you got back well we had a few other complicating factors we had something called punch cards that you guys don't use. Most of the programs are on punch cards. So in addition to debugging the program, we had to get
当时你必须字面意义上地汇编、测试，然后打印出核心转储（core dump）。根据这个，你才能够调试程序。所以如果我们一天能得到一两次周转，那就算走运了。是的，这实际上……这非常类似于我在超级计算、高性能计算领域工作时的经历。如果你有一个在大规模下运行的应用程序，你知道的，你在半台超级计算机或整台超级计算机上运行它，并且你在那个规模下遇到了某种错误，你知道的，你得花 24 小时或 48 小时把作业提交给系统，然后它会去运行，接着你拿回结果，而且这个过程完全不是交互式的。它会在凌晨 3 点左右运行，你只能根据拿回来的结果尽力进行调试。好吧，我们还有一些其他复杂的因素。我们有你们不用打孔卡。大部分程序都在打孔卡上。所以除了调试程序之外，我们还得
a key puncher lined up to repunch the cards and then have someone feed the cards in along with the test material and generate a printout after that. So it was a little more involved than that. It really was. We had also programs. The programs would, at least on a Univac, early Univac machine, I programmed the Univac 3 originally. We had a drum arrangement where the drum actually laid the program. I'm sorry, the program would lay the actual instructions onto a drum. And to execute it, it would execute off the drum. So after debugging the program, you had to go through another exercise where you had to do a, it was a lattice refinement where you had to reduce
找一个打孔员排队重新打孔，然后让人把卡片连同测试材料一起喂进去，在那之后生成打印输出。所以这比那要复杂一些。真的是这样。我们还有程序。这些程序，至少在 Univac 上，早期的 Univac 机器——我最初给 Univac 3 编程——我们有一个磁鼓装置，程序实际上是存放在磁鼓上的。抱歉，程序会将实际指令存储到磁鼓上。要执行它，它就会从磁鼓上执行。所以在调试完程序之后，你必须经历另一个练习，那就是进行格子细化（lattice refinement），你必须减少
or replace the words so it would be an efficient execution of the program. The drum would rotate, and hopefully by the time the drum rotated to the next instruction, it would then execute. Now, if it missed that word and go to another rotation, you had a latency problem which slowed the program down. So in addition to debugging the program, we had to make a latest lattice refinement, make it an efficient distribution of words on a drum itself. So it ran efficiently.
或替换字词，以便程序能够高效执行。磁鼓会旋转，希望当磁鼓旋转到下一条指令时，它就能执行。现在，如果它错过了那个字词而进入了另一次旋转，你就会遇到延迟问题，从而减慢程序运行速度。所以除了调试程序之外，我们还必须做一次格子细化，使字词在磁鼓本身的分布最高效。这样它才能高效运行。
It's like pipelining in the 1950s. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I, wow. That's amazing. I've never, you know, that that's something that, you know, today is done by your processor for you or by your compiler at the worst. It's amazing to think that you used to have to do that by hand. We had, we had to do that ourselves. So that shows you how far you guys progressed. When you were writing a program, like when you were doing the development,
这就像 20世纪 50年代的流水线技术（pipelining）。是的。是的。是的。我，哇。太惊人了。我从来没有……你知道的，那是今天由你的处理器为你代劳，或者最差也由你的编译器代劳的事情。很难想象你以前必须手工作业。我们以前必须自己动手。所以这表明你们这代人进步了多少。当你编写程序时，比如当你进行开发时……
would you just do it on paper and then you'd transfer it to the punch card? We basically used the same techniques you use today. You float shot the logic and you basically translate that into machine language or compiler language, whichever one is appropriate. This would be on coding sheets. You submit the coding sheets to a key punch operator who would punch up the instructions, punch it into the cards and basically submit that to the operator who would do the test. You have to provide your own test material as well, which includes tapes. We did not have things like random access storage at that time.
你是先在纸上写好，然后再转换到打孔卡上吗？我们基本上使用与今天相同的方法。你先构思好逻辑，然后基本上把它翻译成机器语言或编译器语言（视情况而定）。这些会写在编码纸上。你把编码纸交给打孔操作员，他们会将指令打孔到卡片上，然后基本上提交给操作员进行测试。你还得提供自己的测试材料，包括磁带。我们那时候还没有随机存取存储器之类东西。
So we had to provide data in the form of tape as well. And they basically then ran it. And if it didn't work, they would dump it and put it onto a printer and say, fix it. That's basically the process at that time. We thought it was fabulous. The whole technique, we thought it was very, very efficient. But it shows you how far we've gone. Thanks for listening.
所以我们还得提供磁带形式的数据。然后他们基本上就会运行它。如果运行失败，他们会转储数据并打印出来，说：‘去修复它。’这就是当时的基本流程。我们当时觉得这太棒了。整个技术，我们觉得非常非常高效。但这向我们展示了我们已经走得有多远。谢谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and stay tuned for part two next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你喜欢本期节目，并请关注下周的第二部分。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。